le style du monde c'était ne vous faites
aucun souci il reviendra sûrement alors
que si moi j'écrivais il va te
rappliquer t'inquiète ça tapait Claude
sarraude quand on connaît je parle de la
célébrité par la télévision qu'on est
reconnu dans la rue comme vous l'êtes
maintenant après les 50 ans est-ce que
ça change quelque chose à faire plaisir
tu vois c'est comme j'ai du poney un
bain d'eau tiède quand tu sors dans la
rue que les gens viennent ils te disent
oh là là ce que vous êtes mignonne mon
petit-fils vous adore bah écoute c'est
charmant c'est je croyais qu'on le vit
différemment de de quand on a 20 ans
on me reconnaissait beaucoup dans la rue
quand je faisais Jacques Martin tous les
dimanches c'est une émission énormément
populaire quand j'étais aux grosses
têtes et tout et donc ça ne m'a jamais
grisé en quoi que ce soit plus agréable
juste une parenthèse je m'étais dit
quand je quand Claude sarraude sera en
face de moi je poserai la question du
tutoiement alors chez Claude
est-ce que c'est pour l'égalité
je devais avoir 55 ans
je ne crois pas au style et quand j'ai
pris ma vraie chronique d'humour je me
suis dit le style du monde c'était ne
vous faites aucun souci il reviendra
sûrement alors que si moi j'écrivais il
va appliquer t'inquiète ça tapait
immédiatement
j'ai tutoyé donc dès le départ mon mimi
Mitterrand mon Jacquot Chirac et c'est
comme ça que ça commence est-ce que
c'était justement pour en tant que femme
bien vous faire remarquer marquer un je
n'ai jamais pensé à ça j'étais dans un
milieu d'hommes j'ai pas pensé à ma
fluidité une seconde
me penser comme ça si j'étais vachement
coquette et tout je me toujours mais bon
c'est la première fois que je raconte ça
je dis toujours ben c'est parce que je
suis plus belle que tout le monde alors
je peux tutoyer ou bien je dis c'est
parce que j'étais élevé l'anglais était
ma première langue alors il y a pas de
de vous mélangez ça c'est ça qui a
commencé j'ai compris que ce que ça tape
plus fort puis après ça comme tous les
jours il fallait faire la chronique j'ai
commencé à prendre l'habitude de le
faire à la ville aussi mais je ne le
ferai jamais avec quelqu'un de plus
vieux que moi il y en a plus tellement
mais quand je rencontre je
regarde votre ange Claude
je suis une à 75e année bravo et alors
l'année prochaine je vais rentrer dans
ma 76e et là j'ai un petit peu de parce
que là dis-donc 76 ça fait 80 déjà
j'hésite un peu mais je suis parti et
donc moi ce qui me semble important dans
ce que vous avez dit c'est que jamais
vous n'avez dit les hommes d'un côté les
femmes de l'autre les gens il y a des
cons mecs et des fun femme elles sont
absolument pas d'accord du tout surtout
alors que vous êtes battus vous aussi au
côté des femmes
ressentir pour vous même non sans me
ressentir je dois dire que je n'ai
jamais été victime d'une ségrégation sur
sur ce plan là en tant que femme
dans les endroits où j'ai travaillé pas
du tout pas du tout vous pensez que vous
étiez dans un endroit privilégié
peut-être d'être déjà journaliste comme
ça très tôt très jeune dans un journal
comme le monde c'est oui mais j'en ai
bavé au début parce que vois-tu je
voulais être actrice alors ah bon mais
oui j'étais actrice pendant 2 ans
j'avais un truc épouvantable je parlais
faux alors j'ai pu tenir comme ça
pendant deux heures et puis après ça
pour des raisons personnelles parce que
j'adorais les fringues j'avais
terriblement envie d'un manteau et mon
mari de l'époque à qui je tanais toute
la journée tu es un beau manteau tu sais
Faubourg Saint-Honoré et tout il m'a dit
écoute tu m'emmerdes avec ça si tu en as
tellement besoin descendant la rue et
gagne le et là j'ai compris mon malheur
parce qu'en fait il m'entretenait donc
je me suis dit il faut que je me mette à
travailler et je me suis lancé dans le
journalisme mais à mes débuts c'est
certain on était deux trois femmes au
journal on m'a collé comme j'avais été
voulu faire comédienne on m'a mis à la
ligne programme je suis resté des années
à la ligne programme Théâtre du Gymnase
21h j'y suis j'y reste tu es hâte de la
bruyère 20h30 un cauchemar terrible ils
m'ont laissé là pendant des années donc
c'était le choix ou être femme entretenu
ou travailler pour s'en sortir la plus
modeste j'avais vraiment j'ai grimpé les
chaînes mais un tout petit échelon ça
m'a pris des années c'est pour ça que
j'avais déjà je te dis près de 60 ans
quand j'ai commencé la chronique
pour ne rien manquer sur ma chaîne Ina
Mireille Dumas abonnez-vous et activez
la cloche
[Musique]